tiene 13 años y trabaja como Aprendiz de
su tío carpintero en Bagdad durante el
día carga tablas lija la madera o ayuda
a barrer
trabajo como carpintero aquí de 8 de la
mañana a 5 de la tarde y mi padre
también trabaja en carpintería pero en
otro lugar trabajo aquí desde que tenía
8 años y ahora tengo 13
[Música]
Hi that fue expulsado de su escuela por
una pelea y decidió empezar a trabajar
ahora gana menos de 20 dólares a la
semana lo que apenas cubre sus
necesidades y las de su hermana
mis padres no querían que dejara la
escuela pero me negué Así que finalmente
aceptaron entonces decidí trabajar en el
taller de mi tío
Aunque el derecho ir aquí prohíbe el
trabajo de los niños de menos de 15 años
cada vez más de ellos trabajan a causa
de la pobreza y de las desigualdades
económicas muchos son empleados de
peluquerías basureros Olimpia cristales
el trabajo infantil aumenta
constantemente debido a Las Guerras los
desplazamientos y los conflictos que han
tenido lugar sobre todo en las regiones
invadidas por el grupo de estado
islámico muchas familias han perdido sus
medios de vida así que la madre tiene
que dejar trabajar a su hijo para ayudar
a la familia
Busca su estabilidad mientras el grupo
de estado islámico sigue activo en
algunas partes del país además la
administración está aplicada por la
corrupción que vacía las arcas públicas
el estado distribuye ayudas de entre el
96 y 250 dólares al mes para los más
desfavorecidos según el número de hijos